on continue de parler de football au
monde de quelques échelons Nicolas en
National Versailles cale face à
Bourg-en-Bresse une défaite sur le score
de trois butins avec une incidence au
classement les versaillers se font
doubler par Martigues et le Red Star et
le pointe à la 3e place à trois
longueurs de Concarneau et Dunkerque à
la 4e et 5e position et on revient
justement sur cette défaite avec notre
invité par visioconférence c'est
Thibault Jacques joueur du Football Club
de Versailles vont sortir
alors on ne vous entend pas est-ce que
on peut mettre le son en plateau alors
on parlait il y a un instant Nicolas
venait de le dire de cette défaite trois
butins contre Bourg Péronnas qui vous
fait perdre du coup c'est la principale
conséquence au classement à cette
première place du championnat de
National et ça en plus face à votre
ancien club est-ce que la défaite a été
digéré il y a de voilà depuis depuis
cette déconvenue vendredi
oui de toute façon
une échéance qui arrive vendredi donc le
plus important c'est de c'est de vite
switcher et préparer absolument vendredi
pour prendre des points effectivement le
championnat de poursuit un dès vendredi
avec la réception d'Orléans on va en
parler dans un instant alors vous avez
été vous avez été mené assez rapidement
dans ce match et même assez lourdement
de 0 au bout de 24 minutes de jeu
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné face à
Bourg Peronnas
en fait je pense qu'ils ont on a un
petit peu payé cash les deux grosses
occasions qu'ils ont mis de suite et ils
mettent deux beaux buts et voilà après
on court après le score on revient juste
avant la mi-temps et malheureusement ce
penalty
nous nous plombe un petit peu en
deuxième mi-temps ou sinon on était
beaucoup beaucoup mieux et on était
vraiment à porter de d'égaliser ce qu'on
rappelle l'effet du match vous étiez
mené deux buts à zéro il y a eu la
réduction du score juste avant le retour
investir de jeremen Lens qui a marqué
d'ailleurs un très très beau coup franc
on a pu le voir dans les images et
effectivement le trois buts de Bourg
Peronnas en deuxième période pour
Peronnas qui a d'ailleurs fini la
rencontre à 10 puisqu'il y a eu une
exclusion en fin de match j'ai eu alors
peut-être un fait de match vous allez
nous dire si pour vous c'est un fait de
match si c'est anecdotique 22e minute de
jeu avec Kevin fendba qui a été stoppé
de manière irrégulière par un défenseur
Bresson on est juste avant le début à
zéro peut-être un penalty pour
Versailles ou pas en tout cas l'arbitre
a estimé qu'il n'y avait pas penalty
vous estimez que c'est un fait de match
qui a pu changer peut-être un tournant
du match qui a pu changer la suite de la
rencontre ou ça a été anecdotique selon
vous
bah forcément c'est sûr que si on avait
obtenu un penalty à ce moment-là tu
aurais été bien et je pense que revenir
à un moment là du match ça aurait été
important maintenant voilà faut pas se
cacher derrière ça c'est nous on pense
qu'il y avait penalty notre joueur aussi
nous dit qu'il y a penalty maintenant
voilà c'est une décision arbitrale donc
aussi plié et puis comme ça Nicolas avec
le match nul face au puits lors de la
18e journée cette défaite lors de la 19e
journée est-ce que il y a une dynamique
qui est cassée ou finalement c'est ça
reste un anecdotique ces deux matchs
la dynamique forcément avec la défaite
elle a été cassée maintenant il faut
vite repartir si on perd un match tous
les 7 ou 8 matchs je pense qu'on sera
pas mal à la fin donc là on a perdu ce
qu'il faut c'est enchaîner dès vendredi
aller chercher une victoire aller
prendre des points pour relancer la
dynamique et repartir sur une série de
matchs en effet d'ailleurs petite
réaction sur ce but je le disais de
gérer medlen c'est un superbe coup franc
ils sont troisième but de la saison on
commence à sentir vraiment l'impact en
tout cas de l'extérieur vous allez me
dire si de l'intérieur il y a un vrai
impact mais on commence à ressentir
l'extérieur son impact sur le sur le
l'effectif Versailles on rappelle que si
un jour quand même qui a une grosse
expérience derrière lui internationale
néerlandais qui est aussi des matchs qui
comptent des matchs de Coupe du monde à
son actif et ça y est voilà il apporte
vraiment quelque chose en plus dans cet
effectif
voilà que ça fait quoi d'avoir
jérémylens comme comme coéquipier
c'est forcément un atout alors voilà
peut-être que de l'extérieur on pense
que c'est que maintenant qu'il apporte
quelque chose forcément il enchaîne les
matchs donc ils sont de mieux en mieux
mais voilà depuis le début il apporte
son expérience il apporte son calme
c'était vraiment un super joueur mais
aussi une bonne personne donc pour le
groupe c'est positif donc on va voir sur
la suite de la saison le reste de son
apport alors Nicolas le disait vous avez
perdu du coup avec cette défaite la
première place de national mais tout est
serré il faut le il faut le dire
d'ailleurs en haut comme en bas du
classement on rappelle aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de descentes à la fin de cette
saison nationale puisqu'à partir de la
13e place on descend en National 2 vous
êtes seulement à deux points de Marty
qui est l'actuel leader vous vous dites
quoi est-ce que c'est un coup au moral
parce que vous avez dit une dynamique
cassée ou finalement d'être aussi haut
pour un promu parce qu'on rappelle que
Versailles a été promu à l'issue de la
saison dernière bah c'est déjà une très
bonne chose à cette à ce stade de la
saison
alors à ce stade de la saison promis ou
pas c'est une bonne chose d'être là où
on est
aimé garder cette première place ça
c'est sûr mais le plus important c'est
d'être le plus haut possible à la fin du
championnat aujourd'hui on a perdu deux
places mais voilà on est bien dans le
coup on a des matchs importants qui
arrivent à commencer par vendredi contre
Orléans donc voilà pour l'instant tout
tout tourne correctement mais il faut
pas se relâcher parce que comme vous
avez dit c'est serré et il faut surtout
pas prendre de retard on a vu le
classement s'affiche et Nicolas alors
justement si on voit le classement
s'afficher on voit que derrière vous il
y a Dunkerque et Concarneau j'ai regardé
un peu le le calendrier vous recevez
vous allez à Dunkerque pardon le 17
février vous recevez Concarneau le 27
février donc là on note déjà deux matchs
décisifs peut-être pour la fin de la
saison et surtout ce qui se passe aussi
dans le calendrier de Versailles c'est
que Versailles recevra le Red Star le
weekend du 28 au 30 avril et votre
dernier match de la saison qui est le 22
entre le 22 et le 28 mai ce sera à
finalement le suspense va durer jusqu'au
bout de la saison pour vous
finale au dernier match ou pas ça dépend
de notre classement ou de leur
classement eux mais c'est voilà c'est un
championnat compliqué et comme je vous
ai dit il y a un gros mois de février
vous l'avez souligné aussi avec des gros
adversaires donc il faut réussir à être
placé jusqu'à fin mars début avril et
puis après c'est sûr que les points
faudra aller les chercher partout pour
obtenir une des deux premières places
vous avez connu un tibojack une montée
en Ligue 2 c'était avec Chambly lors de
la saison je crois 2018-2019
c'est c'est un objectif avoué
aujourd'hui cette cette montée
potentielle montée déjà en Ligue 2 pour
Versailles qui est déjà promu dans ce
championnat de National
c'est pas que c'est un objectif avoué
c'est juste que à un moment donné
Martigues c'est pareil ils peuvent pas
dire aujourd'hui qui joue le maintien
quand on est en haut du classement on y
prend goût et tout le monde se prend au
jeu après voilà c'est il y a encore
beaucoup de matchs vraiment ça sera fin
mars début avril que là on pourra dire
bon ben on est dans les clous ben là
maintenant on joue clairement la montée
aujourd'hui il y a des grosses échéances
qui arrivent ça va être dur mais voilà
si on arrive à rester en haut le plus
longtemps possible après clairement on
sera là
on note quand même que Thibault n'a pas
prononcé la fameuse expression on prend
les matchs les uns après les autres il y
a quand même un objectif qui est annoncé
pour en regardant la perspective d'ici
fin avril une question justement vous
qui avez connu la Ligue 2 est-ce que
vous pensez que aujourd'hui Versailles a
suffisamment de maturité pour aller
jouer en Ligue 2
oui je pense déjà parce que beaucoup de
joueurs ont connu ce niveau là après
voilà il faut
la Ligue 2 c'est comme le National
forcément plus dur mais voilà il faut
sans cesse se remettre en question donc
la vérité dire sera pas spécialement
celle de demain donc aujourd'hui oui il
y a une bonne équipe des bons joueurs
qui je pense
obtiendrait un maintien en Ligue 2
maintenant l'objectif pour l'instant la
Ligue 2 c'est loin on y est pas encore
donc il faut d'abord travailler dans le
championnat national une toute dernière
question Thibault Jacques on le sait
aussi beaucoup de changements au sein du
club il y a eu l'arrivée d'un nouveau
coach depuis quelques mois Chris qui a
remplacé Youssef chibi c'était en
novembre le départ aussi de directeur
général Jean-Luc Arribart est-ce que ça
pèse dans les têtes ou ça vous arrivez à
en faire totalement abstraction de
forcément de ces changements coulisses
mais qui influe directement comme c'est
l'entraîneur qui influe directement sur
l'équipe première aussi
forcément on est impacté parce que comme
vous l'avez dit l'entraîneur voilà c'est
lui qui dirige l'équipe donc forcément
ça a été des décisions et des choix qui
ont impacté l'équipe maintenant voilà je
pense que le groupe a réussi à faire
abstraction à réussir à avancer et je
pense que ça on voit qu'avec le
classement qu'on a aujourd'hui on a
réussi à mettre de côté tout ça merci
Thibault et on vous souhaite bonne
chance pour la suite de la saison vous
l'avez dit Versailles qui sera sur les
terrains même sur le terrain de Jean
Bouin ce sera ce weekend ce sera même
vendredi une réception d'Orléans merci
d'avoir été avec nous